parfait on s'est rencontrés dans l'avion
si tu vas rencontrer dans l'avion est
rapide facile et suivons ces subi
pendant six heures
ouais c'est le meilleur disquaires du
monde avant petit accent breton
on va faire le blind test on va y aller
ouais alors c'est sa petite équipe s'est
passé lundi c'est ce qui se fait dans la
presse depuis 30 ans mais c'est la
première fois qu'on me prenne à télé
donc il va être passée hindouiste devant
son refus de reconnaître ensuite que tu
me dises c'était bon alors à temps sur
les produits c'est pas très dur offert
chemin parce que c'est moi et bien vous
allez voir ce soir
ah ben oui
c'est quoi c'est le marine
on a assez le mari s'est enhardi way
l'un des nôtres crois que ce soit 168
pas jaloux dû prendre plus soin par
françoise hardy comme ça bon je crois
pas du tout
avant tout cas pas avec le petit aussi
ajouté l'ami de la famille tu vas manger
de dimanche à lundi c'est ça sorry bon
allez la suite alors ça c'est très bien
c'est un bon pas pour toujours
ouais parce qu'arès deuxième morceau un
peu plus vieux
voilà ce que tu sais ce que c'est c'est
sur un album des beatles qui s'appelle
la british il ya quelques trucs pas mal
[Musique]
il connaissait pas remarquer scott
austin et reconnaît de me tuer son boss
ça s'appelle du you know my name et ça
devait être une face b de l'étudiant 70
puis ça l'a jamais fait ça l'est pour
tous les locuteurs de citron quand les
beatles c'est quoi les beatles mais
grande soeur enfin si
c'est toute une époque où j'essaie de la
filtrer dans les boums et comme je t'ai
tout le temps et coûte talons parce que
j'étais en tee shirt
c'est même un caractère non mais ça me
plaisait déjà de participer au bout et
que cela nous y essayer de machines très
dans le monde environ 20 ans ils ont
changé complètement ma vie est ce que
toi ils ont une influence aussi
importante sur toile j'ai raté mes
études à cause des non moi je préférais
laisse tous deux avaient peu avant été
stone plus tôt mais non ce qui a
vraiment changé d'avis et des cigarettes
on a pris un malin car c'était plus le
choc disent que je suis va alors
attention là c'est pas tout lire
c'est un peu plus dur en fait c'est
toujours c'est pas très loin des beatles
non plus son disque apple dans son
rapport avec la mito source ouais ouais
parce qu'ils voient les rangs des ailes
quand même ça s'est bien goupillé
c'est ça l'europe qu'ils n'ont pas c'est
encore plus âgés ainsi encore plus bas
sengoku ravi shankar il était produit
par george harrison c'était dans les
années 75 mais bien joué et c'est vrai
c'est gagne en effet créé le besoin que
les beatles week lâche tu as une chanson
dans ton dernier
33 tours qui s'appelera oui c'est plutôt
j'ai eu une période riche en 15 pouces a
pas très longtemps mais pas longtemps je
crois qu'en échange d'un mouvement
impact ou baballe en ce moment où tu te
trompes ou toute façon s'il est si j'ai
vu le concert de présidence mais
derrière il ya des moments c'est
carrément un manteau fille magnifique
photo
33 60 après 65 pop psychédélique ce que
tu veux qu'ils pensent qu'on va
ressortir les pdf bien qu'on les a déjà
recherchés ils en ont déjà ressenti
brillante on enfin je veux dire à un
niveau plus beaucoup plus visible et
populaire corps qui suivent à 10 que
suivant attention celui-là lé pas simple
[Musique]
c'est rageant mais c'est quand c'est le
rôle des miros
c'est un mec françois cette expression
il faisait quoi bon 77 gt gt album et
puis gsm a filtré ici mais aussi est
très très haut débit via les ports et
puis dans le joaillier jacques nuoffer
les cheaters masse et une époque
important que la première vraie
révolution
les jeunes que j'ai pu me connaître
c'était fond à fond la caisse dans plus
musicalement que que l'estimant terme en
parlant j'ai pas pris une fente à ce
moment là on attaque l'autre au suivant
allez au suivant celui-là il va trouver
aussi parce qu'il aurait aimé ça à ce
qu'on peut dire déjà c'est que c'est
généralement avant de lui planches
presque
hier tout le monde nous a dit pendant à
gauche et comme générique cette année
c'est toi qui joues un peu spéciaux qui
dure une demi heure c'est du voyage un
peu plus loin
enfin ça c'est la partie qui est pas
dans le générique en plus
céline way for éléphants c'est vrai
qu'il est très fort c'est quoi ces
visiteuses ouais c'est dans une bonne
situation
nadine prigent sera préparée versa ya
toute une partie où il chante tout seul
mais après il chante i'm an oui on
appris à boukari re 77 alors à la même
époque y avait des gens qui avaient pas
du tout le même trip ça c'est parce que
c'est aussi la naissance de notre
mouvement parce que ce qu'ils en pensent
de ça aussi ça c'est le palace ouais
et l'effort tu connais mon niveau le
michael zegen ça au sort ne voyait une
reddition maintenant il ya toute une
reddition des vieux tubes disco des
années 77 78 c'est bien parce que c'est
des trucs qu'il faut avoir travaillé moi
je ne sais pas ces pages et dans ce cas
c'est vraiment se [ __ ] des remarques
et idées mais il a pas tort au deuxième
degré je veux dire
l'embellie zoo c'est pas mal alors là
le prochain je le mets ça fait rien on
ose tout quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sap a été un succès 1
c'est très confidentielle présentant
lundi
je pense rien adjani ça je connais pas
centre alsace au petit oiseau sur une
substance aussi inconnu au bataillon
mais je connais c'est l'album à
gainsbourg chirac c'est le disque à la
presse je sais ce que ça implique test
je crois que tu mets des musiques il
faut que je dise que ce avec quoi on la
taille près pas de problème
attention le premier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
combien une intro d'une demi heure on
attend un avis qui ont l'intimé ce que
je sais pas sa visite de bach en algérie
chez fois ci tout à l'heure on en a
parlé c'est mon coeur s'ouvre à la santé
n est pas la clarinette
[Musique]
leurs pas
ça c'est leur foi des gens
tu connais lui alors voilà ouais ouais
ouais je connais bien calé dans son
émission non pourquoi je veux pas y
aller
voici ma ville j'y vais et tout a pas
invité non il n'a pas invité
j'aurais pu y aller péter nadas comme la
même famille d'abord lui l'entente moi
je prends pas en parler c'est la
différence
hachez la différence
au suivant bien sûr que 145 là c'est une
bonne vitesse 70 des américains
ouais c'est un verdict pour lyon je vois
pas à 6 6 a tort il va reconnaître
[Musique]
m
attends c'est bizarre c'est
c'est la première action c'est la
deuxième ce n'est pas bon c'est ça que
je connais la première nation s'est dit
vos satisfactions dans 77 8 ans dit
c'est vrai
il a fait un plan rap est à vous qui
faisait le morceau dark castle ouais ça
a bien fonctionné
l'appétit en est d'ailleurs un bon ouais
style été viré de la télé elle est
revenue à de meilleurs revenus entre
temps de parole
ok on sait bien que les nôtres alors là
c'est bien aussi bien mais c'est
peut-être un peu plus dur à trouver
76 toujours toujours new york impasse
qui murmure je sais moi laissez les
musiques américaines s'est pas remis le
devenu international tu connais
moi je dis oui c'est pas lui c'est un
mec un chapeau blanc super sapec man tp
derrière à ces petits trajets dans le
soap attend les salaires a sonné pascal
et punch d'être acquis
à l'époque ça s'appelait savannah bande
[Applaudissements]
dans cette émission j'aime beaucoup de
ces créatures elle déjà vers semaine
prochaine c'est d'un comique américain
doit connaître au menthol c'est la
famille et de mon spectacle
bref ici ça c'est
celui de guînes melbourne ouais le
cadeau d'un jouet
je suis de bonne bonne bonne bonne
humeur c'est matin c'est ce temps là
papa ça c'est là et je suis sûr qu'il
fait exprès non surtaxé mobylette il a
dessiné bien sûr et ça cartonne
très fort tu vois aubin tous les soirs
sur tout et je crois je sais pas si lui
nous voir si elles étaient membres
cassés mais boîte le bois stups est
ouvert tous les soirs
1 pourquoi tu m'as aubin tous les soirs
parce que c'est pas du théâtre
ouais je sors
tous les soirs après cette attaque tu
voir intimer robin interrogé vous
coucher tu aurais patera des ménages et
à temps mais je crois j'ai habité
produits palace vous l'êtes entendu
parler du blind test de lunettes noires
pour nuits blanches
oui tiens elle m'a dit que c'était
planté toit du tout etienne il a été
parfait il m'a dit que c'était plantes à
isabelle adjani ou avec tout le monde se
serait planté à isabelle adjani avait
corner très bien tiré un très bon
reconnais là scatola oui
perpignan puis bon on y va corte allez
on y va ça c'est pour lui rappeler le
pays
ouais aller à l'avant à la serbie
dario maurice mariano 1 1 3e
au début ensuite
suivant ce que c'est ça c'est quoi c'est
une chanson à toi c'est une chanson de
stone et charden bagages ou entendu ce
matin quand tu ne sais même mec a écrit
en avant fait des trucs comme ça
toujours français adamo stop j'écris à
la gagner tout parler de neige parce que
sur antenne 2 c'est interdit par la
neige mais c'est vrai que tu as fait une
tournée en première partie d' amener à
lever de rideau levé de rideau attention
c'est qu'il y avait à m'excuser après
cette invitation à notre type qui
s'appelle jean valais et joe dassin à
joe dassin générique c'est comme ça que
tu as connu les bus faisons rentrer dans
l'intimité des buffets ou pas puisque sa
survie
j'étais bien content usa bien que du
vent tu continues en continu un peu plus
grand qu'un
tron a joué mais c'est pas bizarre non
on dit alors lui lee lauryn lou reed
voilà générique là c'est la claque
l'ex-animateur gueuler la nasa a été
équipé semaine je crois que c'était
l'époque de l'aventuré
ouais touati s'attaquant même été
vachement influencé par lou reed le
velvet tous à nos influences et non pas
vraiment
tu as entendu la chanson de la vie quand
même des choses oui dans ma vie ils ont
que j'ai vécu ce terrain on continue
alors choisi car alors là c'est rock
aussi en bonne place et elle va trouver
est-ce que déjà le clavier c'est facile
écrit c'est parce que c'est ainsi
tout le monde approuve l oif séparerait
cité sujet
t
je sais qu'il est j'ai dit avant sa
célèbre dans l'essonne
tu l'a connu dans l'essonne un
intimement pas mal j'ai fait comment
dans la vie chalon canon avec ce que tu
vas le voir de quoi il parle
ouais ouais t'as jamais le voir je pense
à lui oui je reste inconnu hendrix aussi
un petit peu aussi fait la même façon
pas de la même façon non et renou des
mick taylor
renault doit commencer leur nom non y'a
des remplaçantes on a fait comme quoi
tout ça veut dire c'est les remplaçants
de brian jones
oui mais bon c'est pas pour ça que je
sais pas mais c'est un peu compliqué
quand même assez ouais je tombe bien la
présentation des stars n'auront pas du
tout oui je suis venu aussi des gens qui
ne sont pas cela
corte
au contraire on laisse ce qui marianne
fait sous la avait justement ouled aouat
compare ma une flèche foule dans la
ville où tu vois tes la marianne
faithfull française n'a pas nui va pas
du tout non peut-être pas bien aimé un
stone wim coutard est de manille avec ça
on dirait que j'existe qu'à travers des
gens qui sont connus c'est pas du tout
cette histoire
marianne faithfull c'est une femme que
j'aime beaucoup je trouve sa façon de
chanter absolument géniale et je pense
que les tiennes il dit ça parce que
peut-être et les montées des descentes
et c'est quoi le titre de la chanson je
tâche connaît l'album superpole quoi
vraiment je trouve qu'elle est calée sur
c'est bien qu'on soit là parce que je le
connais toutes les époques
on se connait la suite
moi j'adore ce qui va arriver là elle
doit aimer aussi
[Musique]
à soixante deux waza jeu cartonne la
coupe de luxe 'non non mais j'adore ça
serait bien c'est donc ça se fait que ce
soit la plus vendue eh ben il faut dire
à tous qu'il faut qu'il aille acheter
non c'est bien pour acheter pour acheter
100 de plus il d'emballer ce que je veux
un petit loyer comme je suis pas tout le
monde que vous voyez moi je préfère vous
par coup je trouve que le goût est comme
une caresse et en réalité je vous vois
tourner le dos conçu oui mais non c'est
non c'est non non pas tout en dépit des
moments très chauds étaient alors à rien
est ce que vous savez ce qu'est un blind
test dont mais je crois qu'il s'agit
plein une servira woerth est bon on va
me tester
ça mes parents à côté ça qu'est ce que
c'est cette oreille non non c'est laid
c'est dans le même cela même région oui
à temps c'est le même côté de l'amérique
oui c'est pas les manquer plus au nord à
l'écrit non c'est inégal à l'onu oui oui
oui oui ça c'est très connu la mairie de
saint ouen non c'est pas de la
génération j'étais trop petit nom sera
joli perçoit j'oublie tout plein de
tendue
c'est celle à l'honneur c'est pas loin
sheila sylvie vartan way coup ce soir
est la plus belle non si je chante on
danse on vous la connaissez oui je la
connais comme enfin je les rencontrer et
je la trouve non seulement intelligent
mais charmant j'aime beaucoup cette
ville où elle habite la moitié de son
temps aux états unis au nom de moi
j'habite toujours par isabelle j'ai un
deuxième front pour faire d un peu
tourner aux états unis c'est pas mal
quand même si avec le nom de je t'aime
tu as beaucoup avec les américains et
d'ailleurs comme je ne veux pas rentrer
dans l'industrie hollywoodienne et faire
des séries série j'ai refusé toutes les
séries la commande la pause et je suis
très content parce que je tourne avec un
suisse oui c'est alain bergala mais
l'égérie drummer et faire des séries
américaines c'est pas mal oui c'est
amusant c'est amusant voilà c'est pour
la faire craquer je sais pas moi je
pense qu'elle va craquer si j'avais été
fige aurait craqué pour lui c'était un
italien un italien sicilien gérer
et
la nar
c'est drôle ce fruit mais c'est pas
frank sinatra selon moi j'ai souhaité
dimanche une phase que dit martine à
russell non je préfère sinatra sur une
île déserte ça se fait du maintien du
cinéma n'ont ni l'un ni l'autre je vais
le concept de l'île des terres oui elle
concept de l'américain d'une
cinquantaine d'années non on savait -
gifi a sa chance alors voilà un ca à
saborder
les signes et l'autre ouais contemporain
c'est peut-être le vin de meilleur
groupe français
faut pas avoir peur des mots
mais ce n'est pas le moment
c'est moi téléphone
on sait mieux
oui c'est les meilleurs
c'est les meilleurs moi je
le plus de mourhino
on les appelle plus rita mitsouko les
appels de fuite de la vidéo
non non mais l on l'a fait constamment
j'ai vu que vous aimez connaissances et
les seuls que j'aime suivant alors ça
c'est ce mot ce jeu pratiquement un slow
avec une fille là je meurs moi j'aime
pas les slogans
bell mears et ses grands parents
c'est là dessus
mouais tout le monde connait sa mère
mais qui le chante
ah oui c'est ok choix des noms 1 comment
je m'éclipse c'est qu'à six lettres
jouer dit elle on l'a dit un demi point
est-ce qu'on est indulgent aujourd'hui
mais je peux vous la chanter tout cela
mais
zéro
[Musique]
elle a trouvé ça fait deuxièmement c'est
quoi est-il du morceau sex machine
[Musique]
en même temps comme passion avant tout
les participants
un finger
un petit plat 10 ans filles qui était
habillé en fille maintenant les cheveux
courts
merci bonjour vous savez bah oui mais je
voyais un gîte qui ne baisse que la vie
chère elle savait le sol est simple mais
vous savez ça sent la diff ex-aequo
ouennoughi 4g par mes lunettes
y'en a combien conscient et l'attaqué
moi j'arrive je suis assez facile
[Musique]
[Rires]
en
pour moi c'est ça
le type même équipe et nous voilà voilà
je mets même temps on peut dire le
double des relatant ses concerts
[Musique]
ok
m
ces norvégiens fils
ha ha ha à l'école mais j'aurais pas d'y
jouer
pourquoi mais pourquoi la team dubai
je dois les tortues bleus
[Musique]
c'est quoi le jeu c'est grippe la mouche
de colonna qui s'est extrait du jus dans
des tentes et des policiers voilà voilà
ça s'appelle comment ça horrible je
mendie des fans de justin
et puis ça a été un démon ajouté à
l'impression des pieds je n'étais pas
vraiment fan j'ai découvert six étaient
quatre voilà ça lui en fait six familles
que c'est au juste
joli trimestre révisé à regarder lycée
devant devenue malheureusement en ce
moment j'ai pas beaucoup de temps mais
j'espère ne pas tromper
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les quartiers en avant pour le
problème entre le premier la bande des
quatre
les beatles 4 encore en douze ans la
bande des cas de gale c'est un des
beatles
pas les noms
c'est pas le mec c'est pas ledit permis
on a fait un truc a pas longtemps
harrison comment il s'appelle george
harrison
écoutez les visages à la maison band est
petit on les écoutait qui j'étais tout
simplement comme j'ai 30 ans quand tu as
fait ton père
non mais ma soeur les écouter beaucoup
parce qu'elle est la plus âgée que moi
moi je les écoutais pas vraiment mais
elle avait tous les disques alors
j'écoute à la maison qu'est ce qu'il
écoute ton père comme musique à part ça
je sais pas on écoute la musique à la
maison
foot par exemple moi j'adore rester ça
m'échappe
j'étais bien j'ai appuyé pour tous
objets la sphère louis triaud les frères
touré kunda et d'amis zucco j'ai pas
tout ce que tout le monde écoute ainsi
que des files non là ça je connais par
coeur
le mec vachement ces pays les morceaux
directement je sais pas visiblement
attendu l'avant dernier disque un truc
c'est à moi ce soir tu vas voir ce qui
est bien c'est à dire non je n'étais pas
là mais j'ai bien aimé encore dans le
trou pour des soins dans quoi bon aller
carrément état du disque est là je me
dis tu connais pas encore très bien
compte qu'une seule dans une boîte qui
peut pas tout acheter mais ça y est tout
menno meyjes connaissent la même
attention un peu plus dur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je connais la loi nome et les paroles
ont changé entre temps
selon la chanson les noms mais n'a pas
et c'est patrick king live à travers
l'échangé au portillon
c'est chiche en salle avec la mise en
scène est alors que près de 70 des prêts
dès lors qu'on a dit on au betis et je
suis même endroit branché par mois
dorment ici mais nombreux sont marginaux
musicaux mais j'en sais pas très bien ce
qu'ils viennent de lui michelin gagne
elle est écrite les bourgeons de plaisir
non mais j'avais tout ce que je voulais
alors à bon ouais non je n'ai pas
vraiment eu mais si j'en voulais je
prouve en avoir mais j'en ai pas demandé
je pouvais acheter tout ce que je
voulais à 11
oui est élevé à la dure non si tu gagnes
b
durant toute personne la victoire en
tête de l'eau
[Musique]
c est comme ça que je prends les trois
essais ça y est c'est le français 3 mois
salaires font tant d'années s'est fait
[Musique]
jeter les parents de cet enfant 10 ya
deux méthodes qui sont sur un bateau il
y en a un qui tombe à l'eau des
aborigènes en nouvelle calédonie majin
l'audition des parents biologiques mais
on continue ouais
pourtant c'est fou ce que je mets la
plupart souvent plusieurs
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche j'me
souviens plus très bien
j'adore de fer couleurs à oui alors ça
tue moi pour moi chez sa mère
[Musique]
mais non parce que c'est de la variété
chez d'essayer parole sublime moi je
rêverais montchamp trafford comme ça en
fait avec un autre rythme des roms et
qu'on puisse avoir d'aussi bonnes
paroles
c'est génial c'est écoute les paroles
aviaire c'est elle qui le fait
musicien en jam vous êtes prêts pour le
fameux blind test mais absolument
y a que des filles et des sites a
l'impression de reconnaître un mec tu
dis toi que tu t'es bourré d'accord
voilà on y va à corti
m
mais c'est une contre a maille à tous
les belges d'une tonne alors je n'aime
pas les 10 la plus grande chanteuse
portugaise temps et femmes et 65
écoute moi je te remets ian paice km 65
je crois que je suis quand même après
une bonne dizaine de centimètres d'eux
en leur jeu souvent fruits met tout de
suite en soit mme alia 2010 leurs talons
bas linda écoute dans la troisième
dimension sous peine d'être la première
bon soulevant sa longueur ces potaches
ont montré qu'il est un comble quand on
sait les mêmes qualités
le jeune étudiante et sa capacité à nous
adapter
j'ai chanté avec et des constantes
changer les choses du bon côté que crée
cette bonne chance
[Musique]
on continue à la trouver
la c30 cale du lot bayonne schengen
écoute moi je veux dire on l'écoutera
fifa et moi il ya la zone de france gall
que j'adore c'est beaucoup et je connais
par coeur et sait pas honte de dire
j'adore danser
de plus depuis que moi mais je continue
à trouver quelle est la halle à l entrée
dans la voix elle a du charme de son
affaire continue
justin justin conn de gaza c
za trop
c'est pas de petits dons
[Musique]
oh
cegid a blanchi ville et qu'ils ne
regardent pas les rondelles
ils ont collé
c'est mardi que la chanter non non non
non ça c'était vraiment pour anis et
j'adore c'est plein de ça j'ai trouvé ça
pas bien l'intérêt l'a dit on m'a fait
faire des conneries c'est fatigant
qu'elle fasse ici de sa famille
à quoi calmer lui siffle pas
il retrouve tétouan viable
[Musique]
[Rires]
la chanteuse va bien
et
elle dit qu'elle entend pas viable c'est
bien ici de la voix est bien derrière la
musique a mon avis oui mais quelle façon
je sais pas c'est quoi les petits
jeunesse de jambon journée
rodilhan garde côtes et l'instrumental
ware la raison
amateur des halles pourquoi elle fait
peur tu l'as vu dans des conditions
d'isolement de 7,50 et elle monte au top
50 la couverture de télé 7 jours c'est
la grimpette la peur c'est bien mais
écoute moi je suis pas au top 50
tu la vois tout le temps et ligne à je
ne vois pas du tout droit qui l'a démis
l'époque où la tuer la pape d'abord en
non je n'ai pas beaucoup vu elle est
jalouse de foix iii comprend enfin eva
joly bonne copine par m
non on est pas copine du tout on est on
est juste de toucher pas à l'époque
amoureux solitaires copine mais oui mais
moi j'étais koudrine des hommes et je
pense que j'aimerais bien la foire mai
du calme toute façon l apal temps a
beaucoup fait en france n'auront pas le
temps est la suivante au walhalla les
pancakes pathogènes
on continue entre tribus c'est bien de
bronze mental n'a jamais rien tous les
modèles report one and ont alors passé
tout près de faire les runaways
ouais et oui je sais elle est facile à
être une chanson pour les renier
tapez indoor ashton il a écrit intime
personnel
ouais je suis une petite fille j'ai 14
ans et j'écris quand même des meilleurs
chevaux
quatre modèles élégants pour la suite
laurent levy avec ben ouais vous n'êtes
pas boire assez durs dans le mariole va
trouver un nom mais coûte mon fils y a
des gens qui sont allés dans le tout est
là vous n'êtes pas là écoute bien ouais
mais ce qui attire bon an mal an ba oui
c'est paul serra et bartoli
le rockeur dès 2010 elle est celui qui
faisait comme ça j'ai entendu c'est bon
ouais c'est bien c'est juste là bas les
instruments dans les oreilles et il
chante la voix c'est grand mais c'est
plus rock rd2 sans blague on dit
toujours que c'est john lui il est même
que le salit pas repris par poule c
c'est insensé quoi à soyouz st hubert
quand même
[Rires]
le 8 août chaque cas je me souviens
qu'on s'aime et désherbants
je pense au brésil tu oublies
je sais c'est pas vrai non
duke se le dise non
oui c'est une chanson de vertes bakara
qui a été chanté par et en france et
eddy mitchell toujours un coin qui me
rappelle mes ouais on l'applaudît permis
alors deuxième
[Musique]
ah t'es vraiment un petit américain
je lui dis c'est un peu plus longtemps
déjà arrêté d un mur
[Musique]
merci à lui et il y a
c'est riche intelligent temps c'est
mieux
mais oui la petite place
qui plus est on
le musée
le rebond
deux jeunes fils thomas
parce que je suis né
olivier panis et blanc franck alamo en
anglais à la maison
mais qui
derrière chambéry jake berry bros
[Musique]
bah oui
est ce que dit ouais ouais
et ça s'appelle comment qui a répondu ça
c'était chanter maintenant si c'est
simple et chanson française voit la
chance dans leur vie mais qui chante en
anglais j'ai pu dans le groupe du monde
pour en bout du monde on va voir sur les
d'accord sauf que quand vous demandez
je pense pas
et
avec un exemple bilou
ouais les beatles the beatles rats ils
parlent tellement avec laquelle on
l'applaudît dollars
oui
entre-temps j'ai un vide
non tu finis je t'attendrai jusqu'à
minuit oui
[Musique]
m
il
c'est coucher trop tard ces monstres et
cie je te lis tu regardes
bien entendu
midnight à warwick seul t4
qu'est-ce que je suis moche aller au
suivant il a trouvé c'est parce que tu
m'a servi des traits qui l'avait
pourtant le dieu vivant
ouais gros coeur c'est un anglais que
j'entends patinoire c'est ce qu'ils
disent toujours ça va
tournoi
c'est un anglais ouais c'est un anglais
qui s'est beaucoup déguisé dans sa vie
qui secoue birkin well well well well
well comment il s'appelle c'est le plus
grand cube de mark knopfler
sarr soir entre qui m'a demandé ça
j'allais bon
j'en ai d'ailleurs ce live c'est bien le
seul à gagner déjà notre boutique du
disque est vraiment seul et j'ai
vraiment gagner à la morgan yens
tendu et se le dise que je trouve mais
il a écouté les mêmes
sultana on l'applaudît parce qu'il a
droit aux lunettes noires c'est tout ce
qu'on gagne c'est qu'est ce que tu veux
c'est non mais c'est la télé d'état ici
on ne peut pas donner des dépassements
non c'est très très très bien le
rappeler
[Musique]
tu lui
du tri
je connais bien
[Musique]
bah oui c'est la bonne nouvelle la
version originale et vous me demandez
quoi qui chante je peux pas vous le dire
tu sais pas non alors 0 déjà tu veux
avoir honte
c'était idole mon pote c'est les beatles
ah oui c'est vrai avec tony sheridan
j'ai dit tony sheridan quand même
ouais ouais salut famille points 1/2
vous le dire que les balais riddle david
hallyday n'en connaît pas eddy mitchell
c'est grave quand même tu sais pas ce
que c'est vicieux on enregistre hambourg
ouais ben on passe au suivant au suivant
alors là c'est le vice à la vous êtes
tués
vous êtes vraiment dur mais non ça c'est
pas dur c'est pas dur c'est impossible
pour trouver
toute façon on dirait macartney
m
tu
la voix de me garder mais
moi quand j'ai reçu sachets pas d'où ça
vient j'ai reçue c'est un jour je crois
que c'est un morceau de macartney
[Musique]
moi je crois que c'est un hacker
s'appelle tags
maintenant ces défis h terrible ça fait
acheter réponse suivant il a voulu
commencer à guy bourgeois times
s'intéresse d'ailleurs si nous regardons
jeu attaque il peut nous écrire parce
qu'on sait pas on s'est fait chier c'est
très joli très joli
keystone s'annonce assez pâle et sur la
version originale et et nestor
dans la région en français c'est des
filles 1 g de are
non mais je connais
[Musique]
oui c'est ronnie va oui oui
elle me dit qu elle m'attend
[Applaudissements]
shine the city les babines tombera oui
et pas plus de chance et bastia ouais
j'aime bien les gars su'l
cette voix me dit quelque chose ray la
chanson je la connais pas obtenu
ses 15 sites web non non c'est pas à lui
faire plaisir c'est quelqu'un d'un
groupe très connu
keith richards ouais ouais ça s'appelle
militaire c'est sur 130 points
voilà ouais
a priori ça ressemble aux beach boys
ouais je sais pas les beatles assez
[Musique]
c'est bizarre lakers s'assurent aux
beach boys ce serait brienne où il se
voit la wii
[Applaudissements]
en échec il était sorti les déductions
je me suis dit c'est les coeurs des
beach boys c'est peut-être là une bonne
de brian wilson
il est mal à l'aise et celle ci ses
aventures
c'est ça la culture
[Musique]
récent ouais je
pour s en rendre août prochain ouais
c'est rita mitsouko oui
cet apport bat le record de dawn le
dernier on l'a trouvé là le dernier à
l'avoir
ces derniers là on arrive au dernier je
suis là ouais d'écouter les paroles ya
la partie on ne souffle pas c'est tout
instrument chetout instrumentale
ah ouais bon alors je vais citer
quelques noms suis sûr tomber dedans
n'ont pas droit non non elle a plein
déjà la cas d'yvette horner derrière toi
bah ouais bon ben alors verschueren
alors oui en vrai
[Applaudissements]
tout est d'accord pour nuits blanches
oui oui je connais bien oui je sais
c'est pour ça que je suis très inquiet
c'est à réviser mais non justement
alors voilà je ne sais pas ça et et
l'indicatif de salut les copains pendant
des années
je sais pas ce que c'est d'abord
[Musique]
débarqué à oui c'est ça devait débarquer
et marquez ça s'est démarqué elle
reconnaît pas l'indicatif de salut les
copains des copains
[Musique]
ces spécialistes passent les bornes
c'est gagner à l'est
[Musique]
tu mets un bémol à papeete la jeunesse
chez b capital
voilà là qu'est ce que c'est ça
mais m
alors c'est gloria je suis moi qui
chante et ça
cette fédé demi point en additionnant
les demi point d'arrêt
oui bon ça c'est votre dylan c'est
comment et certains morceaux
[Musique]
avant ce soir
danger une afrique
a paris il m'a invité dans sa chambre à
l'hôtel george sand
oui y aller et puis je suis allée imac
lanterne rouge
j'ai vraiment vu son bétail avait rien à
craindre et
y avait cette chanson en dessous et just
like a woman qui m'a fait entendre c'est
bien j'adorais chicoine strauss kahn
félix était bien les a sortis de la voix
[Applaudissements]
samedi quelque chose mais comme je n'ai
jamais acheté le dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
la sas et genre de truc que j'aime
beaucoup j'ai trouvé que ce sera trop
tard
[Musique]
là
j'ai pensé à crise
je connaissais
ces pièges et avertit tout de suite
tiens en estrie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ses fils de john moore la bravo
julian lennon le fils de john lennon la
plus dure
[Applaudissements]
malcom encore du boulot
voilà c'est première fois que j'ai un
contrat
[Musique]
oui mais je connais presley ou pas par
peggy lee et en français tu connais pas
non sur sa très mauvaise nouvelle ça
allait faire plaisir c'est un belge en
fait c'est une journée les gazelles à
oui je me suis ça s'était bien passé
beaucoup moins bien
il faut alors j ai no string comment les
immersive et qu' il faut que je change
de nom elle va changer de nom
si tu trouves pas séduit
[Musique]
c'est la chaussure
annick
éthique
oh
[Applaudissements]
l'agencé le tour de france annoncé york
s'est pas produit si père le magicien
le magicien d'oz ses malédictions futurs
invités lunettes noires
[Musique]
je n'écoute de retraite aurait laissé
rosemont toujours rangé
marie elle s'en fout
celui-là corti supprime le big show made
man
m
j'ai entendu ça te fera mais j'écoute
souvent des radios qui ne désamorce et
n'annonce sa présence sur ce marché qui
chante l'insatiable ont pris un soin
très joli tapis si complexe chanteur un
peu dans l'élite à 20h30
il est marié que
wen comédiens la brume et des musiques
de films il éblouit ressemble un peu
mensonges et son nom
bon alors que le dire mais c'est bien
vous à dubrulle battue elle s'est mariée
mais je pense à lui non mais je connais
je vois très bien qui c'est mais je
françois valéry heures
pension valérie si douce bon après si
l'on suit la chaussée entre le magic
pascal rapaud est une institution je
trouve pas ça reste figé
[Musique]
oh
7e et 10e
cet automne à plein de la production de
ton dernier album je veux pas pourquoi
d'ailleurs mais pourquoi tu t'es jamais
fait produire par daho
[Musique]
parce que toute façon aux mamans gfr
ce qui faisait le sien et non j'ai pensé
quand même mais j'ai pensé un moment où
il venait de produire
tess est un groupe quand je vous dis
elle longe prochain tu devrais penser à
dawn j'ai fais pas de franchi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]